parti on y va marine le pen c'est vous
qui avaient été tirés au sort pour
prendre la parole en premier
[Musique]
dans le monde du grand art in de la
france c'est son peuple marine le pen
oserais-je alors que le débat à peine
commencé vous interrompre juste pour
vous rappeler que nous voulions avec la
vous poser un anneau dans les mêmes
termes pour une durée d'une minute
trente la question suivante qui nous
empêchera évidemment pas de vous
exprimer vous avez donc une minute
trente l'un et l'autre et vous donc
d'abord marine le pen en quoi seriez
vous une meilleure présidente que votre
adversaire emmanuel macron je veux
démarrer avant même je vous avais parlé
ça la musique ne pouvait reprendre le
crédit vous sera remis aux gens avant
lever les on a enlevé les seconds j'en
suis absolument navré en était
[Musique]